you
monsters vs. aliens how can you go wrong
with a title like that you don't well
for the most part the film definitely
gives what it promises monsters vs.
aliens but sometimes they give some
really lame really not well thought-out
jokes but to make up for that I think it
gives us some very memorable characters
most of them anyway had a very creative
premise the story starts off with a
woman named Susan was about to get
married but through of course a tragic
accident
she transforms herself into a giant and
is captured by the government to be used
as well a weapon freak of nature so they
put her with the other weapon freaks of
nature including a big eyed scientist
the missing link and a one-eyed blob for
the most part they just keep him there
safe until some sort of threat ever
comes by and wouldn't you know it a
threat comes by aliens from another
planet start to invade the earth the
president played by Stephen Colbert
tells him to send in their top men or
freaks this is where our four heroes
come in can they stop this invasion
while also trying to find their place to
fit in with humanity the film suggests
yes but let's not jump to conclusions
the strength of the movie does come from
our main character Susan she was
planning just to be an everyday
housewife with a nice normal life when
suddenly this freak accident occurred
and she plays it away where you really
do feel legitimately sorry for her
her fiance turns out to be a jerk
everybody's horrified of her even though
she would never harm a mouse and now the
army wants to use her as a weapon to
destroy even though she has no training
whatsoever her problems are definitely
the heart of the movie but that's not
the only thing - like Seth Rogen is the
blob with a one eye and he gets a few
good lines Colbert is the president is
pretty much as funny as it sounds he led
alien Rufus
evidently date led get on the chopper
I'm ready
I am a brave president and even the evil
aliens get a good giggle here there I
found out my parents were no child
should ever have to endure that so I
went on the road with a giant for the
film falls flat is sort of the other
characters I've been missing link I
don't really remember that much and the
scientists I don't really remember that
much some of the jokes range from kind
of good idea to just kind of stupid yeah
remember that scene and sometimes the
animation can be a little odd oh no
sometimes the people look a little too
weird to me but again they sort of level
that out with some really creative
action sequences and do a great job in
giving everybody their size and scope
especially considering the fact that
they make Susan the main character so
you can get a lot of fun angles with
height size that way so on the whole
monsters vs. aliens isn't a super strong
film but I think it's enjoyable to watch
at least once maybe even twice any time
a joke sort of keels over and dies they
always make up with it with either a lot
of heart or a lot of action it's a fun
flick and definitely worth your time to
check out
you